hello everyone welcome back to my
channel PGH InDesign today I'm answering
question from my youtube subscriber
how to make a split ring so we are going
to do the design on the split ring and I
also like to talk about how to flow the
stone on the ring shank if you're
interesting in the middle part for Hetal
ring that's another video talk about how
to make them and also the prong set
please see the link below are you ready
let's get started
[Music]
so we are going to starting with the
ring shank and again if you're
interesting about how to make this part
for petal ring you can take a look on
the video link below and we were
starting about the ring shank so I'm
going to starting at the front and set
it up my ring shank diameter is 16 and
the reason I put it have this in this
propulsion is I will need to trim it off
later on so I need to actually have it
extra thick the only thing you want to
pay attention is about right here
the culet of the stone right about in
the in the tip of the stone you don't
want to get below the ring shank area
otherwise you will cut it into it okay
so I'm going to keep this in this area
and I'm gonna lock it so we won't
accidentally to move it alright so now
let's take a look on the right view in
the right view I'm going to draw a curve
and it's roughly it's going to be like
this and it's gonna coming up and it
will roughly going something like this
alright so I'll go is to have a shank on
the side view look like this now a lot
of time named when you are trying to
work on the right view you may snapping
into somewhere else so at the front view
it look really weird so what we wanted
to do
as we go to the rival again and we
picked up this curve and that's go ahead
to do project choose C plane so what it
does and we want to delete the input
object so what it does is it gives a
really flat curve which is completely
flat to the construction plane alright
so now we have this one we are going to
use the command is leaving under the
curve you have this one curve from to
view but let's go ahead to record a
history first and then let's go ahead to
do the curve from the to view so we're
gonna click this curve as a ring shank
and this curve very quickly you're going
to get this curve right here now if we
look at it and it is way too far away we
may need to edit at this point so for
example if you turn on a control point
you can actually say well I actually
like to come out a little bit and you
can see that curve is actually follow
with your original curve okay so I'm
going to keep it like this and decided
where is my ring shank and thickness is
going to be I'm gonna draw a rectangular
and snapping to the bottom of that ring
shank for example I'm gonna have my
stone this one point a millimeter so I
may want to have a length for about like
two millimeter or two point two two
point one depends if you want to have a
radius so that's set it for two point
two and then the second number is how
thick you wanted the ring shank to be
I'm going to set it at two all right so
this is my profile is going to be and
that's move it back to from the midpoint
back to the quadrant alright so that's
our first one the second one I'm simply
just gonna copy from the midpoint to the
cause unfold the other one alright so
let's take a look now it feel like it is
way too far from the center part so what
we can do is we want to move it back you
want to offer lapping just a little bit
to see you know to make sure you can
bowling it really well so let's do a
test and see if this way were work we're
going to do the test with the surface
tool under the surface you have sweep
one rail so let's pick up this curve and
this to us a cross-section and make sure
they all align I usually like them
aligned in the middle of the Ring in
inside of the ring shank all right and
we need to make make sure we close the
sweep so we will have something like
this and take a look if you like that
and if you don't and you can adjust it
at my point this is might be like too
tall for it so I may need to reduce the
height of it so it won't look like it is
coming up too much so I'm going to
delete this one and I actually it wasn't
touching the point I wasn't good
what I mean is this need to be touch of
this no one there is too high okay and
that will make sure it's not going way
too much it's just you just need to have
it touch it a little bit alright so it
looked good I'm going to sweep one more
time under the surface you have sweet
one rail this is your rail this is your
cross section and that's move the arrow
inside and facing the same
direction and don't forget to close the
sweet all right now you have that one so
we just need to take the look if it
looked good on both of them on it so we
want to mirror that just do a test and
see how it looks all right so now you
have this over there
you can design about on the ring shank
sweep again with the other profile if
you like to do that
but I will leave it that to you and also
you can design some something like
cluster in the middle area Oh like the
one I have a big trillion stone in this
area to fill it up okay the second part
I would like to talk about is how to
flow the storm on the top I'm going to
did it one of it and I'm gonna use this
as my reference to do the storm to flow
okay so I need to decide where my stone
is going to flow I definitely not going
to flow till the bottom of the ring
shank so I wanted to flow somewhere
until there okay I'm gonna mirror this
guy to the other side and then I'm going
to trim it off the bottom of it
alright so now I trim it off I only need
the surface on the top I actually don't
need anything else on the button so I'm
going to delete anything I don't need it
just won't get confused alright so this
is the area that we are going to have
the stone on top of it alright the
command we are going to use is create UV
curve we're gonna create a UV curve over
here and as you see the it doesn't look
rectangular they look a little bit like
like pointed it's because when we are
cutting at the front view and
the ring is actually split it's kind of
having a curve that's why you can see on
the right view over here it is pointing
on one side so that's actually correct
it's actually going to help us to flow
it back you all know the direction okay
so the next step is we need to arrange
the stone on it all right so I call out
a stone is about one point eight
millimeter and if you want to know how I
make this stone you can go to the link
below in the description I will have a
link over there on my other video of how
to make a stone so I'm going to move the
stone through the position that I like
it's better to have it right in the
middle so I'm going to use the align
tool and we want to ally in the middle
all right so now this one is a line we
are going to design the prong let's go
ahead to draw a prong roughly anywhere
about here and let's go to the right
view holding the shift' you want to draw
a straight line we wanted to do is just
simply pipe in okay so let's go ahead to
pipe this guy and we can have it kind of
eyeball it for whatever thickness what
we want for this pipe and it would be
something like this this is really
aesthetic decision about how thicker you
wanted to have your prom however you
don't want to you prong to be cut it too
much a usually you wanna stay as 30% of
the prong to maintain the structure and
fold the better casting all right so
let's do a test we are going to move the
prong inside of the line that we have
and we want to mirror that prong let's
go to mirror to the other side and see
how they
look all right and then that's doing
Mira one more time this time I want to
do is to have that stone to mirror to
the other side all right so this is well
be like how the prong is actually
holding let me enlarge the table you
kind of see it this stone is not cutting
way too much of it I will try to keep it
30% as possible and this one as well now
if we move the stone out just a little
bit we can actually move the prong
inside of it a little bit all right so
that give us a little bit room to the
outside H that your prom won't be file
off too much and that actually will look
better so this will be a good position
so I'm going to did it one more time and
try to mirror one more time to see how
they look you may need to do a couple
times to make sure that that is the
distance you want and then we will have
this one two mirror to the other side as
well by using the midpoint here all
right so this distant looked good to me
and I'm going to have them and they come
in I'm gonna use is the array it's
called lean near array I'm going to
array how many of it I'm not so sure I'm
gonna try more than I need we're gonna
type it 15 here and first reference
point it's going to be the midpoint and
we try to hold a shift and come back a
little bit here so make sure that it's
really close to what we had and I now
have an extra stone on it you did it
alright so it looks really well we may
need to have this one
title copy back to the first left side
of the first stone and we did have too
much so I'm going to delete one of them
okay it looked like fitting into our
space really well so I'm gonna pick up
all my prong and stone let's go ahead to
group them and let's do one more time is
to align with them this time
I'm going to use the center align so
that way of right side and left side
will be equal distance okay next what
we're going to do is we need to flow it
back so let's go ahead to make that's a
curve into the surface by surface from
planar curve alright so let's take a
look on the perspective view so you kind
of get an idea of where the prong is
going to be and that's flow it back the
command we are going to use is transfer
transform under the transform you have
flow along the surface you're going to
pick up the prong and you're gonna pick
up the corner and that's flow it let me
see
let's flow it back to this corner
and sometimes you'll get something like
this I'm gonna keep it this as a
tutorial right there the mean our
direction is not correct so you might
need to try a few times to get it
correct I was clicking on this corner to
that corner a parody I'm clicking on the
opposite corner so I'm gonna try it one
more time here click on this corner and
this corner instead so now it flows
really well and we just need to double
make sure that you know they are not
flipping or anything like that now our
song is on it we no longer admit the
surface because that was just for the
reference and I'm going to create
another layer and put all the stone and
everything into that layer and temporary
just close it alright so the reason I'm
doing this is because I need to redesign
my shank a little bit because my shank
was using a profile of this really
square looking profile and that is going
to make the where is not comfortable so
I'm gonna use that as a reference and
use the conic corners and redesign my
profile it's going to have a little bit
round profile and something like that ok
so that that look good to me and I'm
gonna make a copy too from the mid part
of the button to the me part of it there
okay so that way I will have a rounder
smoother corner and let's take a look
all full view and look okay to me so
let's use the new profile to do the
sweep going to the surface you have
sweep one rail you pick up your rail and
this time we want to pick up the new
profile so let's go ahead to pick up a
new profile hit enter make sure that you
bring the same to inside of the ring
shank and facing the same
direction and let's go ahead to close
the sweep all right as you can see the
corner is nicer it's not as sharp as
that one and we can bring you back our
stone right there
all right look really nice and then we
can have them to pick up both of them
and to me row to the other side
all right so that is for the split ring
and also how to flow the stone on the
top of it I hope you enjoy the video and
again if you're interesting in any of
the model in the Rhino and you'd like to
know how to make it please email me or
you can leave the comment below and so I
can think about if I can find a way to
design a tutorial for you thank you for
watching and I will see you next Monday